what are we doing here well you know you
said I always looked like a dolphin with
my shirt off yeah
that you're gonna be the one that looks
like a dolphin
let's go meet your technician how are
you okay pleasure good to meet you there
is there gonna be any blood situation
I hope not that's not the answer we're
gonna figure it out yeah okay
that already doesn't feel good now I'm
really making sure that I'm getting it
in there yep
that was not fast quick or Payless you
want to see can I tell you something
that's a lot of hair sir yeah
Jesus Christ
this part feels like it's been some time
coming that's an awful picture for an
older brother to take of his younger
brother see you at home
yeah you nailed it